[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen ladies and
gentlemen ladies and gentlemen ladies
and gentlemen ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen ladies and
gentlemen sometimes omits the money on
the line and the skill on display it's
easy to forget that games are supposed
to be fun oh my god oh my god we gonna
fight but she knows what's down in this
world we often look up to the greatest
neighbors the flashiest players and the
most prolific superstars but this story
is an exception to that rule this story
is about a guy who's just like you and
me I'm built like a chug chug like that
horizontally gifted what did you say
[Music]
logan edit my girlfriend right here
they forgot the e they forgot that you a
goofball a normal dude a class clown
whose voice has served as the backdrop
for some of esports biggest moments he's
willed himself through sheer passion to
the top of the gaming world his name his
courage and this is his story jack
courage Dunlop is eSports everyman he
was never an a mur a superstar or a pro
he was just a kid who wanted to be part
of something and like many he caught the
FPS bug with the release of Halo 3
September 25th 2007 and I'd barely keep
track I don't remember that day no it's
blue one of the things days of my life
was a the day my life truly changed for
gaming was September 25th 2007 when halo
3 released and from that moment on his
relationship with games was anything but
casual the players the shots and all the
biggest moments only fueled his passion
to get involved in the scene and even
back then courage had the same energy
you see from him today
hey guys what's going on courage here bu
my first ever video here today I am so
excited to get this channel started
finally the new year is here and I am
ready to provide great content for you
guys throughout this next year and for
the future of my life that should be a
lot of fun this is my first ever video
so I don't have an inch from or outro so
I'm just going to go he knew he needed
to find his way into eSports and funny
enough the way he did that was due to
his favorite game Halo seeing a decline
in their eSports scene Starcraft was on
the rise MLG was hosting nightly Call of
Duty matches and League of Legends was
soaring to the top of the eSports world
and then courage got his big break
one day MLG's only host Chris Puckett
sick and couldn't do the daily eSports
report I was kind of a sat there in the
background and there on Christmas like
I'm gonna be out sick we have a cancel
the show and like I have literally just
went I think I can do it
I don't really Brian and ROM looking at
me and then like on speaker probably
like Chris he's like let's do it
give him a chance so July 21st 2014 as a
summer intern courage stepped up to the
mic for the first time in his young
career hello ladies and gentlemen and
welcome back to the east board support
my name is Jack Dunlap I'm filling in
for Chris Puckett as he is home not
feeling too well today but we're wishing
Chris the best luck on getting better
but we are here talking call of duty
today in the MLG studios to finish the
report that day and would go on to
co-host it for 45 consecutive days until
he went back to school at the end of the
summer just a few months later in
November of 2014
call of duty advanced warfare hit the
shelves and the game's first major event
was to be held at MLG Columbus few
months down the road it was like
afternoon who called it a had come out
next you know I get a call from Puckett
and I'm like hey what's up he's like hey
our first event for advanced warfare is
literally nine days from now in Columbus
Ohio
have you ever commented before Mike no
he's like God either you do it like yeah
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to the
Bravo stream here at the MLG aww open my
name is Jack courage Dunlop and I'm
joined here by the legend himself I'm
excited to uh excited me Cassidy other
mammals eight
still sitting at 17 and 8 now
controlling the cell and positive 10
making sure neatness whenever he needs
there dripping and someone else in a
half there the game is completely over
now is only 50 seconds remain you know
phase it's gonna be gunning for that 250
here as they're gonna take map one great
SART off of this base line in the span
of a year
courage went from a sports fanatic to a
summer intern working behind the scenes
at MLG to a talk show host and finally a
shoutcaster a voice of eSports and there
was one special moment that elevated him
into a household name
there was an SMD match there playing the
match it's an intense moment and because
we were on two different connections the
MLG connection studio got kicked from a
lobby for some reason all the people at
home can see is Puckett and mr. access
to do being like we got kicked in the
lobby hopefully we'll find out who won
it like what it's done but then I was
like wait I'm still in here they're like
radio cast of forest and Here I am like
all right I just go like now we see
teepee pushing on towards main room he's
got one in front of him gets the
elimination tries us about the second
dashes around the quarter 1vs1
17 seconds left teepee with the bomb
he's got to go for the plant he's gonna
try to stick it I don't know
can I just radio cats the whole thing
and I remember like Matt doing his like
laughs and puck it going you're higher
than they just like freaked out reacted
to it and I was like what just happened
and from that moment on he never looked
back MLG hired him as a full-time caster
and he and his casting partner maven
became the faces of Call of Duty's
eSports scene but he was ambitious and
he wanted more he didn't just want to be
a caster or tied to any one game he
wanted to be Courage the gamer a
one-stop shop for your gaming content
hey guys what's going on courage you
bring another video here today I just
started streaming three Fridays ago and
today we had over 170 viewers and stream
throughout the whole thing chat was
bumping we were having thought I hit
that quick 360 no-scope
right on them well four straight let's
go baby
I'm going off right now you would've
thought I was a pro player with this
accuracies my dudes okay that's a little
ridiculous but that didn't mean he was
leaving the casting desk far from it
late in 2015 courage announced that he'd
signed on with the newly formed call of
duty world league as one of their
primary on-air talents and it was with
that announcement that his career truly
took off
simply put there was no competitive call
of duty without courage he was the sound
of the game
Hey with the wind three two one peekaboo
[Music]
courage spent three years as a caster
for the cod world League and as eSports
was trending upwards so was he in
September of 2017 fortnight Battle
Royale was unleashed on the gaming world
it caught the attention of every gamer
on the planet and changed everything we
thought we knew about gaming streaming
and celebrity and for someone like
courage who was growing his name and his
stream it was the perfect cross-section
of entertainment and gaming he was
consistently streaming to more than a
thousand viewers at a time growing on
YouTube and social media all while
becoming a household name in eSports
[Music]
he's got this way of making you feel
like his best friend through your
monitor that is unmatched in the eSports
world because like you he's just trying
to have fun on the internet ninja do the
voice of ninja yo yo
but did you just say to me a little and
it's that passion that draws you in the
self-deprecating humor and his trademark
ladies and gentlemen soundbite you know
that white makes your titties look
bigger yeah Marion part of my sex appeal
you not learn from seeing other
streamers on twitch your body kind of
looks like a gourd Tim I get it I'm
built like a chug chug dog I'm built
like a chug job but still doesn't mean
that just because I have nice form
truest man titties doesn't mean that a
strong independent woman can't enjoy
them I'm not fat I'm horizontally gifted
in fact he was seeing so much success
focusing on his own channels and
Fortnight content that he left his job
casting the call of duty world league
and signed with optic gaming as a solo
content creator
Ninja has hosted you with 129,000 428
viewers be Irie did I just [ __ ] myself
yeah go clean yourself up right now to
say that at that point he blew up would
be an understatement much like all of
FPS eSports when courage first entered
the scene in 2014
fortnight was young and immensely
popular but it still needed its
community to be patched together early
on there were good players and big
streamers faces like ninja and dr. Lupo
that were pulling the community along
then came the tournaments specifically
team stars fortnight Friday or many of
the biggest names got their start
including courage
got him let's go baby that's my teammate
good job jack that much in many ways
courage filled the void the community
needed a voice and when Epic Games
announced their overwhelming 100 million
dollar commitment to fortnight eSports
he was one voice in particular that
everyone knew would be a part of the
broadcast here he goes he's got one
layer on him $5,000 richer incredible
entertainment across the last four days
and now it all comes down to basically
we wait for the standings but what an
honor it has been to be part of all this
so so much fun but during this meteoric
rise courage was met with yet another
turning point in his career optic gaming
was dealing with structural issues
internally and courage was growing his
own brand far bigger than he could ever
imagine so he made the leap and left
optic uh jack
he just left optic like two days ago
yeah two days ago you know I feel I feel
like this is his mentality it was
definitely my mentality so I can speak
for myself it was like well I'm not
gonna try to be like super passionate
about you know helping out content if we
get here and like there's there's no
organization of anything and then he
really really really blew up and and as
soon as he blew up like that I was like
it's no way so I was like yeah it's only
a minute
over the course of 2018 courage became
one of the faces of fortnight he along
with the likes of Ninja dr. Lupo Tim the
tap man and other massive names like T
foo became the celebrities of this
massive new game all of these
personalities bring something unique
you've got ninja superstar swagger and
over-the-top attitude Lupo's aggressive
humor and fatherly tone and T Fu's
incredible aim and nonchalant attitude
and then there's courage
[Music]
me somebody in a lot of ways he's the
embodiment of content first he's kind of
competitive but also focused on creating
a fun environment
he's just fortnight's nice normal guy
and nothing embodies that like his
relationship with Connor hello have you
won a game yet on Stubbs
I barely win no early on and for
tonight's streaming days courage became
popular for his random duo Q Phil games
where he Q into a dual game and pair
randomly with an unknowing player and
one of those players was an 11 year old
kid named Connor who's your favorite
Avenger
I'd have to say Captain America oh good
choice have a huge fan of Iron Man I
just like how he's got a lot of money
and has a I told you we get that wait
for you dude there might not be any
single thing more courage than his
friendship with Connor
since their first meeting they played
together all the time and Connors had a
chance to meet all of Courage's close
friends on stream how's it going are you
Connor
look you got to meet the tap man
[Music]
what's really unique is how honest he is
about it all millions of YouTube
subscribers later and a massive twitch
stream he still are everyman it's like
when you click past his blue and gold
logo you've signed the social contract
he's going to plug twitch Prime and to
support a creator code but he's not
going to hide it
twitch out to be such critique
interpretive activities after dating
Twitter to be subscribing Wow Jack built
this himself
I thought that was just a seer gift for
my friend pay my friends we've got a
flash card JT go check it out
twitter.com slash / GG twitch on TV / /
JT youtube.com slash / JT insignificant
/ for JT discord OGD such courage eh
he'll be linked right here on the screen
in the description on all day in shop
social medias go subscribe to me see you
guys next time be sure to leave a like
in this video and what would it be a
real outrun without plugging at courage
ad a whole major social medias in May
2009 teen courage joined a hundred
thieves he had ties to nadeshot from the
Call of Duty days and the org felt like
the perfect fit they were young had a
bit of swagger to their name and focused
on content first when you have me
involve content as always possible use
here make sure you're ready I'm
definitely I would not try that yeah
either you guys should do that your big
human beings
what's this must mean you're telling me
that right now my do that every girl
would love me coming over right right
yeah yeah
leave a like in the video if you guys
want it and when courage joined a
hundred thieves the voice of call of
duty and fortnight became one of the
voices of gaming he was a vlogger a
celebrity a member of the girthquake duo
with Tim the tap man and all around
online talking head and nowhere is this
more apparent than his extremely public
and 100% not a joke love affair with
international superstar ariana grande
first off she can sing brilliant whistle
tones I can sing brilliant whistle tones
[Music]
second we both know how to dance very
well that everyone should know I am the
fat ariana grande in conjunction with
100 thieves co-owner and Ariana's agent
Scooter Braun courage and a hundred
thieves have created a series of content
surrounding him attempting to land a
date with her it's become one of the
most beloved story lines in the
Fortnight world and it has absolutely
nothing to do with gaming dude I haven't
talked to you well I think all you guys
since music video what you think it was
awesome you talk to me I've watched it
over 10 times you know Ben I decided
that humba shoot
shop moon and ask her out on a dinner
date which I still of her background she
might as well get in the gym you know
imagine being as successful as ariana
grande and choosing jack what seemed
like an ambitious and lovable joke
became international news overnight
Jack's tribute to his favorite artist
was watched by millions and was trending
worldwide on YouTube and Twitter not bad
for a 4/9 gamer there's a lot of stories
in the gaming world about a kid who
started making videos in front of a
scuffed webcam to one day make it big
become the face of Call of Duty or cast
a 30 million dollar eSports event kicks
off today and I could not be more
excited dr. Lupo this is gonna be a darn
good time but courage is a little
different than that there's something
closer to home about him he's not the
best gamer in the world
he doesn't make inspiring plays or have
a professional eSports resume what
courage shows you is passion an
unrelenting love for what he's doing
what he's creating and who he's working
for that he wears on his sleeve for
everyone to see
he self-deprecating just because I have
nice voluptuous man titties doesn't mean
a strong independent woman can't enjoy
them he's loud
it is humble surreal dude it was so
tough to leave MLG behind and delete
beta behind me but you guys supporting
it meets the world
really does thank you he's your voice on
the other end of the screen The Voice
the Internet
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
bring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages